make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are near the end we have
one more video left until we're
completely and totally done with
hickman's avengers and new avengers what
a ride it's been it's been pretty wild
hasn't it
right it's been pretty crazy hasn't but
this is when we finally get to the point
where we talk about the origin of the
incursions how it all started
why it's all happening the whole nine
yards so uh what we end up doing here is
we pick up
two weeks before like two weeks ago and
you've basically got
a gathering of the illuminati you've got
black panther you've got reed richards
you've got brian braddock captain
britain you've got the incredible hulk
you've got uh beast and you have
black bolt of the inhumans and all of
them have assembled around the cage
containing tony stark
right superior iron man and what they're
basically saying here is that there's
been no small debate
they're trying to figure out what to do
with iron man because this meeting takes
place
right before captain america and his
forces meet up with the illuminati to
find out what they're going to do about
the incursions right that event that
video that we covered previously what we
end up getting here is this this kind of
thing where the idea of tony stark being
there
is kind of important because it is tony
stark and he's so wildly intelligent and
capable
the problem with this is the history
between tony stark
and captain america right remember that
what what kind of happened here is
you had the events of of the incursions
kick-starting right so we had iron man
trying to distract captain america with
the avengers machine like they had wiped
his mind at the beginning of the whole
thing like the original civil war event
it was it's all these scenarios that
have taken place over the years where
this kind of
distrust has grown between captain
america and tony stark leading up to the
point where captain america just sort of
sees him as like almost his mortal enemy
and so if they allow
tony stark to be there this uneasy truce
between the illuminati and the forces of
captain america could completely come to
an end and so the best thing to do is to
get him out of there right to just
remove him from there not only that iron
man wants to die for something but he
doesn't want to like die in a cage and
that's what's so crazy is because
despite all of this
iron man still has an ace up his sleeve
and so ultimately they end up letting
him leap right they end up letting him
get out here's the irony about all this
too
the true sin of tony stark is lost on
everyone here right the worst thing iron
man
has ever done is lost on everybody here
none of them really know
the worst thing that he's done so far
right it just seems bad and so
ultimately the cage is destroyed and
iron man is just kind of let loose right
he's just basically told
leave do not come back here right like
go and do your whole thing you know do
do whatever is that you want to do right
like die well it's the last day for it
but we don't ever want to see you again
right he's officially been cast out of
the illuminati now at this point we
switched to two hours ago right so we're
kind of back in the in the current
moment but two hours beforehand and we
have gladiator who basically speaks to
the entire inhabitants of earth right
just kind of shows up with like a
hologram different things like that and
basically says
you know most of you here on this world
will never truly know
the depths that your superheroes have
gone to to save your world
you just don't know because they don't
tell you right but recently we fought in
a war against the builders
this multiversal race that was traveling
from one universe to the next and wiping
out the different earths that they came
across
and because of the help of your earth's
superheroes we managed to stop them and
we managed to
wipe out most of the builder fleet what
was left escape with their lives they
fled with their lives right we saw that
when we ended up getting the tale of of
of hank pym that what was left of the
builder fleet all consolidated in a
singular location and then tried to
track down the map makers and we saw
what happened to them
right basically the builders have all
pretty much been wiped out now by the
either by humanity or by the map makers
sent by the by the ivory kings by the by
the beyonders
and so because of this what you end up
getting is basically like
gladiators saying it doesn't stop there
but it doesn't just stop at our war you
know at the war with the builders your
earth's heroes have saved us during the
events of like maximum security they
they saved us during like the events of
the original secret wars and the
follow-up in secret wars 2 when the
beyonder came to your world they saved
us on a multitude of occasions
operation galactic storm all these
things your earth superheroes have saved
the world increased girl war
it's happened over and over and over
again and so it's with a heavy heart
that i tell you now
despite all the things that your heroes
have done and all the greatness that
humanity has bestowed upon the universe
and the times in which it saved us
your earth is the reason why the
universe is going to end and so in order
to preserve the universe we're going to
destroy your world you've got
two hours and it's just like damn son
like you hey
hey humanity you got two hours to get
your affairs in order like if you want
to escape the world
now's the time to do it ah good luck
peace like it's basically
it you got two hours to get while the
getting is good and that's when the
earth superheroes are like okay but
notice this they don't panic
especially captain america and this is
the benefit this is the biggest benefit
of steve rogers in the grand scheme of
things steve rogers ain't that great
right he can just run really fast and
punch really hard rahu but when it comes
down to like battle scenarios he is the
guy that you want in your corner because
he keeps a level head right he keeps his
head cool
whine back to the initial meeting that
happened between captain america's
forces and the illuminati right there's
a point where captain america is talking
to reed richards and one of the things
that reed says
is that the intelligence difference
between himself and tony stark is
is fractional but the big difference
between tony stark's intelligence and
reed richard's intelligence is that reed
is smart but he's usually single-minded
right he focuses on one particular thing
the only time when he ever really
focused on a grand number of things
was during jonathan hickman's fantastic
four run when he was trying to solve the
problem of everything
but usually whenever reed is working on
you know using his intelligence is to
solve a particular problem when that
problem is solved he moves on to the
next one tony stark
is not that way tony stark is the
greatest multitasker in the entirety of
the marvel universe
it's basically like if there were 15 or
20 reed richards all working on
different things at the same time
that's what makes tony stark so
intelligent that's what makes him so
capable
he can focus on multiple earth-saving
strategies at the same time right he's
just always looking into the future and
he's always thinking
what comes next right i'm in this
scenario i'm not thinking about the
scenario in the moment
i'm thinking about what it's going to
look like in five years or 10 years or
something like that
that like we mentioned in the previous
video is one of the most important
things that you need to remember that
you
absolutely have to remember it's one of
the most important things right this
ability of tony stark
to look to the future and to see what
shape things are going to look like to
see what real chance of success they
have
that's going to be the biggest sin of
tony stark the big like the worst thing
he ever did that's what all this is
going to be it's all going to lead to
that particular point it's it's a mate
like when it's revealed it's amazing
right it's absolutely amazing but
uh reed richards basically gives captain
america this device created by tony
stark right created by iron man and it's
just
one of the many things that he was
working on is for him it was almost like
a little side project
this device basically you know it
controls an object hidden within jupiter
and this object within jupiter is one of
the planet killers of the builders from
the builder war during infinity do you i
don't know if you guys recall that but
it was one of the vessels one of the the
devices that the the builders used to
wipe out an entire world and it's
more than enough to destroy an armada
and this is one of the things that tony
stark was working on in the in the
with the whole builder award everything
going on while tony stark wasn't
necessarily there he understood the
power of the builders and said hey
we might need this at some point but we
might need to use this and so we
basically constructed a device that
would allow them to remotely control
that planet killing ship it's just it's
just one of these things just one of the
little things that tony stark had up his
sleeve
the other part of that is of course we
end up learning that uh that izzy that
that you know super guardian
didn't join the shiar guard right she
didn't join uh gladiator when he
basically told her like you need to
evacuate because we're gonna wipe out
the world her response was
no i can't do this like i'm i cannot do
this like i cannot turn my back on my
people
i cannot side against humanity right
everybody that i know is here if you ask
me to do anything else i will but i
cannot do that one thing right and so
ultimately she sides against the
imperial guard she stays alongside
humanity the other part of this
is that at some point in the early days
of the incursions that what what
advanced idea
mechanics had been working on was a
series of satellites and these
satellites combined with robert de
casa's ability to basically kind of keep
them going
under the finances that he was offering
advanced idea mechanics the idea
was to have these satellites basically
harness the thermal energy of the earth
and that when that was done they could
literally fire off that thermal energy
so literally they could just use the
heat of the earth as a weapon
and fire it off and that's exactly what
happens the issue with this is two-fold
the first is that because of the sheer
amount of energy this thing is able to
enter
able to use as soon as it's charged they
have to fire it right off the bat
because if they don't the cr and
the various armadas who are here they're
gonna realize how powerful this energy
signature is and they're gonna move out
of the way or they're gonna be prepared
for it right and so it's like as soon as
this is charged up we have to fire right
so it's like pulling a gun right as soon
as you pull it you have to shoot
otherwise you know they're going to be
able to react accordingly and so with
that in mind
as soon as this thing powers up it fires
off and annihilates a massive portion of
the armada
and gladiator in them they don't even
know what happened right they're like
what in the like what was that like what
it what just happened
man and it's like like we didn't know
they had like we didn't know earth had
that kind of technology we didn't know
they had the ability to utilize the
entirety of a planet's
energy and fire it off at people and and
one of the things gladiator says is like
how many
times are we really going to
underestimate humans and it makes sense
right because some of the most powerful
beings in the entirety of the universe
hail from humanity right the marquee of
death the molecule man owen reese
franklin richards like matthew malloy
you know mad jim jasper's like all these
super powerful beings are human right
even protege from the alternate reality
is a human this it's just how powerful
these guys are well i guess he was
really more engineered but nonetheless
you know protege is kind of a special
example but it's kind of like okay so
the response of gladiator is
then ready our vessels you know and
prepare for another attack
right as soon as that happens you
immediately have the the planet killer
ship that arrives on the scene
and so from one side literally from the
back of the armada you've got the planet
killing ship on the from earth itself
you've got this massive energy source
getting ready to fire off and it's like
the entire armada is cornered there's
really nowhere for them to go and it's
like holy cow
earthlings have cornered an entire
armada composed of of
some of the oldest races in the entirety
of the universe and captain america's
like opened fire and they literally just
start attacking like this like this
planet killer
just starts annihilating uh all these
different races right like starts
annihilating the the entirety of the
armada the issue with this
right the the the wrench in the works
comes into play when robert de costa
goes to fire up the weapon again and
he's told by one of his science advisors
do not do that like if you fire this up
and you keep doing that like we're pro
you're going to approach a critical
threshold and like we're going to lose
this facility and the cost is like why
would we stop man like why would we stop
doing this like we've got him on the run
he goes to fire it off again
and destroys the facility right their
connection to the satellites are lost
the planetary weapon is gone the cr
immediately pick up on this and they're
like okay the planetary weapons gone
alert the creed the scrolls the badoon
alert them all let them know that earth
has no more defenses right earth
earth defense is down now and his
response is unlike send forth the
annihilation wave right the forces of
annihilus which in turn
will swarm the planet killer the planet
killing ship which is exactly what they
do they swarm the whole thing and
destroy it right so now
earth has no real defense left there's
seemingly no real defense here but earth
still kind of
has its ace up asleep and it comes in
the form of the illuminati if you guys
remember the video that we did before
where you had the rogue planet that came
out of nowhere that was basically sent
there from franklin richards and
the avengers world in the future it was
sent when franklin richard said it's
being sent from the future to that point
in time because the earth would need it
this is the reason why that when the the
planet was coming in when it was when it
was heading on a collision course and it
was going to crash in the earth the only
way to save the planet was to phase it
right was to basically
create a device that would allow the the
earth and the planet to kind of operate
in the same space at the same time and
it moved the planet
out of faith so it was basically like a
hologram more or less and so what this
did is because it made that red rogue
earth intangible it allowed them to
occupy the same space what the
illuminati do
is they switch they make the the earth
itself intangible and they make the
actual world tangible
and so essentially it provides a kind of
layer of protection they would have to
destroy that red earth in order to get
to or i guess destroy that red world
that rogue world
in order to get to earth and it's not
designed to be like a finality it's a
stopgap measure and the reason why it's
a stopgap measure is because the last
great thing tony stark does right the
great thing that tony stark does
is he basically chimes into reed
richards right this kind of jumps back a
little bit but he chimes into reed
richards and it's one of these things
where they have a conversation and tony
says like in reality like a gravity well
it's just a massive reactor right like
that's really all the
the sun is it's just a massive reactor
right it's essentially an atomic bomb in
space
what if we could harness that energy and
what if we could use the sun as a weapon
remember tony stark made that dyson
sphere remember that was one of the
things that tony stark was working on in
the early days of the incursions this
is why jonathan hickman writing is so
good because everything becomes
important at the end of the whole run
see you guys understand why
i love jonathan hickman's offenders and
new avengers
so much because all these things that
seemed innocuous
and unimportant and irrelevant at the
beginning of the story and you find
yourself asking what does this have to
do with anything
all becomes important at the end and
that's the whole thing right like iron
man is basically intending
to to fire up the dyson sphere and use
the sun as a weapon
and it's one of these things where like
as soon as iron man heard the armada
right
the the the space-faring armada of the
cree and the scrolls and the shia and
the badoon and the the brood and all
those guys were heading towards earth he
immediately made a b-line for for saul's
anvil and it's one of these things where
he kind of makes this quote and saying i
am icarus and the response of tony stark
is you do know the point of that story
was that he flew too close to the sun
and lost his wings and iron man gives
the best response ever and he says you
know who thinks that way reid
and reid says who and he says people who
have never flown switch over
to doctor doom right see this this this
this
man let me tell y'all something man this
is this is this is
man it's amazing right it's just it's
such an amazing story okay
pick up with dr doom and the molecule
man owen reese
the last before we we picked up with the
idea that doctor doom was verbuma
the last time we saw them is they had
just kind of disappeared together and we
didn't really know where they went to
what they end up doing here is basically
you know kind of using a device and
traveling throughout time
and space they go back 25 years into an
alternate reality
and the whole thing is that molecule man
wants to show dr doom something right he
wants to help him understand
what it is that needs to happen here
what he shows him
is the origin of this of molecule man in
an alternate reality and you've got
bowen reese in this alternate universe
basically working on a device we can
assume it's acme atomic corporation we
don't really know that's where the main
marvel universe owen reese was working
at when he got his powers but this
alternate reality version of owen is
working on a device
right he's working on this thing the
device ends up you know kind of
activating accidentally and blasts him
with a boatload of energy
and he basically just kind of emerges
with all this god-like power he's a
walking talking cosmic cube
the exact same origin as the main marvel
universe owen reese and and and
the main marvel universe owen reese
walks up to his alternate you know
ultimate reality counterpart and just
kind of starts talking to him and says
like do you remember
you know that that when we were younger
that there was you know that it was
spring and we were chasing a friend
right we were chasing them through the
woods there was this beautiful white
flower that was growing beside a large
oak tree that it caught our attention we
stopped running
so we could lean down and smell it they
both lived this this whole experience
and so the molecule man
in turn kills this alternate reality
counterpart right he kills that version
of himself
and and and literally it's kind of like
this is what we have to do now right it
obliterates the entirety of his universe
it wipes out the entirety of that
universe and the process right the
destruction of that molecule man
basically kills everything and that's
what's kind of cool is because doctor
doom still doesn't quite understand
what's going on he's like i don't
understand
this right you know a molecule man's
like this is what you have to do like
that memory of me
is now gone that memory that i had of
that moment we were running around and
we were in the in the forest and going
after that white or you know stopping
for that white flower
that memory is now gone that part of me
is now dead that's just the way that it
is
and he says this is what you must now do
doctor doom and doctor who's like i
don't understand what you're talking
about like what what does this mean
you know and he's like this is how this
this is how people end up becoming
calling you the great destroyer and he
hands him the knife
he's like i don't understand exactly
what you're referring to so what he does
what molecule man does is he takes
doctor doom to the library of worlds and
says there was a time in the marvel
multiverse there was a time here when
the beyonders from the beyond verse were
observing our multiverse right and they
used the library of worlds to do it they
were like scientists who were literally
watching our multiverse like a petri
dish wanted to see how it worked they
wanted to understand
all this kind of stuff you know before
they got to where they are now before
they constructed this grand plan they
were trying to understand us
and he says the library of worlds is
where they did it right it is from this
place that you will operate and it's
from this place that you will do
everything in your power to stop the
beyonders you have to understand
i am not a human in the traditional
sense i am not a being in a normal
sense you know i'm basically a bomb of
the of the beyonders and this is where
we start to get this kind of full-on
explanation of how all this works and
what all's coming together what the
molecule man says
is that in all the different alternate
realities that are out there there are
alternate versions of doctor doom now
notice this he says
that that there that he the doctor doom
is somewhat unique in the sense that
there are less of him than there should
be that's a direct reference to jonathan
hickman's fantastic four
if you guys remember if you either read
that story or you saw our coverage on
that story that one of the things that
was happening is that with the council
of reed richards all these reads from
alternate realities they were going to
different universes they were taking
different versions of doctor doom and
they were lobotomizing him and they were
sticking him down in the bottom of the
citadel that's why owen reese says that
doctor doom's unique in the sense that
there's not one version of him in every
reality because while there was
at one point those different alternate
reality versions were taken and they
were lobotomized but
unlike you know different universes
where you know where dr doom might be a
poet or he might be a good man or
something like that
every version of owen reese across the
universe or across the multiverse
is the exact same his origin is the
exact same the life he lived is the
exact same there is no differentiation
it is exactly the same so imagine if the
life you lived up to this point
where you're watching this video that
this version of yourself was the exact
same across the multiverse and that's
the nature of owen reese and that's why
he says i am the bomb of the beyonders
the grand scheme that these guys have
right
where they use the library of worlds and
they were observing the multiverse they
were curious how life in the multiverse
works the next step was
well let's destroy it all like let's
just blow it all up and let's just see
what happens right but if we're gonna
blow up every single universe how do we
amass
enough energy to pull that off okay so
here's what we're going to do
in every single universe that's out
there we are going to engineer
a a scenario right we're going to create
a life source and this life source that
progress is going to happen though
happen the same way across every single
universe so in every single universe
owen reese is born into the world and
and he basically grows up with that
same life until he becomes an adult he
gets a job at some kind of technological
institution that might be the only thing
that changes but he gets some job as
some kind of technological institution
he works on
on a kind of system that can basically
create cosmic cubes he ends up creating
one but ultimately there's no
containment device for that cube and so
basically he absorbs a portion of the
beyonder's power the other portion
gravitates out into that universe
it becomes the beyonder from the
original secret war so every reality has
his own version of the original secret
wars from 1984 that child version of the
beyonder is ultimately defeated and then
eventually a molecule man and and that
beyonder are coalesced into a singular
entity and then he basically goes
forward with the full brunt of the power
of the beyonders basically you know and
then he kind of lives his life going
forward from there
it's always the same and so the idea was
we created him right the beyonders
created the molecule man he's imbued
with
all that power and their goal is to
detonate to literally blow up every
single molecule man
at the same time that's the idea that's
the whole goal it's like putting a stick
of dynamite in every room at your house
and then detonating them all at the same
time you blow your house of smithereens
that's what the beyonders want to do and
what the molecule man tells dr doom is
this will wipe out the entirety of the
multiverse you have to stop them and the
only way to stop them
is to deactivate the bomb but because of
the fact that every version of me
because we've gone to this point now
where every version of me comes into
existence the only real option you have
is you can basically try to stop me you
can you can go back further in time if
you want to
but ultimately like i will end up coming
to existence there's no way to stop that
so the only way to really stop the bomb
is to kill me as soon as my powers
activate right as soon as as soon as i
basically
gain my abilities or once i've gained my
abilities to kill me right that's the
only way to do it you have to travel
from every universe to the next and
where dr doom says why is this simply my
task why aren't you gonna come with me
the molecule man says
because basically all these versions of
myself we share a singular mind we all
have the same memories with each version
of myself that you destroy
i will lose a portion of myself in the
process right so it's like if you
traveled around the multiverse and
killed all your mercy reversal
counterparts or all your multiversal
counterparts were killed
each time you would lose a little less
intelligence right you would lose a
little bit of yourself now the bit of
yourself you would lose is microscopic
but the more versions of yourself that
are destroyed the more of yourself you
will lose right so where 0.00001
of yourself will be lost with the first
version of you that dies by the time you
get to destroying a hundred thousand
versions of yourself
you've lost percentages like literally
whole percentages of your brain right
you've lost percentages of your mind you
would steadily go insane and it would
get to the point where you would just be
kind of a vegetable
more or less right so that's why
molecule man says i mean i can go with
you on this but understand that by the
time you get to the to a point where
you've destroyed enough universes i'm
gonna be useless here and that's where
dr doom kind of asked the question
what's the point of all this right like
why travel from one universe to the next
and destroy you and he says because
if you do that that yes it'll destroy
the universe like
yes you will basically be killing me and
by virtue of doing that the energy that
i let off will destroy
entire universes but you're 25 years
into the past right now which means you
have 25 years
until we get to the point where doctor
strange meets you in the in the library
of worlds and so you have 25 years to
kill
as many of me as you can across the
entirety of the multiverse the hope of
this
is that it'll basically stop the
beyonder's ability to detonate all of me
at one time that instead you'll be able
to save something you'll be able to save
some measure of the multiverse that's
the origin of the incursions the event
that we talked about in the very
beginning of jonathan hickman's avengers
new avengers an event happened that led
to the destruction of that world and it
started a cascading effect that led to
the universes crashing into each other
that was doctor doom killing molecule
man in an alternate reality it wiped out
that universe it created an explosive
blast
and pushes the universes next to it into
the ones next to those universes and so
the idea here is that doctor doom is
basically
racing through time he's racing through
time and racing through alternate
realities
trying to kill as many molecule man as
he possibly can whilst trying to
stabilize all those things at the same
time now the reality of this is that the
incursions was an
unintended consequence of what dr doom
did but it was a necessary result
it had to happen there was no way to
stop it right we knew the incursions
were going to happen and doctor doom
knew they would but the idea was to
travel through as many univer
universes as he could and kill as many
molecule men as he possibly could to
save at least something because by the
time they got to the point where the
incursions were taking place
the idea was they could try to stabilize
things that that they could kind of keep
the incursions from happening or slow
them down
or something along those lines and
ultimately save the multiverse in the
process right and by whatever manner and
whatever means because the multiverse
exists by way of just
decisions that are being made right so
doctor you know doctor strange decides
not to become the source or supreme you
know and instead it becomes somebody
else that's an alternate reality that
the multiverse will eventually come back
right just by virtue of people's
decision-making processes if if a
possibility exists there exists a
universe for it and so it'll come back
in no time at all and so on his journey
what he ends up coming across really
when he wipes out a molecule man he ends
up coming across a young girl who
escaped a sentinel camp right so this
looks like a universe where the signals
have taken over the world uh much like
we saw in like days of future past and
because of what he did you know she kind
of asked why did you do that and he says
because the death of the molecule man
will spare universes right it'll it'll
basically spare all of reality now
notice dr doom has kind of hidden this
image from this girl she doesn't really
know what he looks like
instead he's just kind of a bright light
so nobody really knows what his face is
and nobody can really understand what
he's doing because they don't know that
it's dr doom doing it and so what he
ends up realizing is that he needs to
create a religion that because of the
fact that a few what is it
when when owen reese is talking to him
and says that like you know you've only
killed a few thousand of me over the
course of the last five years you're
gonna have to kill
billions and billions of me to really
affect the plans of the beyonders doctor
doom realizes i need more people to do
this
right i can't just do this on my own i
need an army to do it for me but i need
armies of people that can literally
travel around the multiverse with me and
kill as many molecule men as we possibly
can and so that's when he ends up
creating the black swans right the black
swans originate in doctor doom's desire
to kill as many molecule men as he could
and he couldn't do it enough on his own
now
while he's doing that 10 years in the
beyonders began to realize
something's wrong that like molecule men
across the across the multiverse are
being destroyed because of what use
would they be a scientist
if they weren't monitoring things why do
they say we're going to create all these
molecule men we're going to detonate
them all at the same time they would be
terrible scientists if they just create
a molecule man and then never paid
attention to what happened to them and
so when one molecule man gets destroyed
they can kind of chalk that up and say
okay like maybe it was just something
that went wrong maybe it was one of
these you maybe was like a dark phoenix
saga in their universe and like it led
to the destruction of their whole
universe because the phoenix went nuts
in that in that universe who knows right
one molecule man is no loss
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands millions of molecule men dying
something's wrong here right something's
off and so what what the beyonders did
is they basically created a virus they
created a computer code and what this
would do is it would spread throughout
the multiverse and
any particular computer organism that
that achieved
self-awareness uh would and and had the
ability to train to basically leave its
own universe and go into the multiverse
itself would eventually become
corrupted by this virus and it would be
turned into a map maker you guys saw
that with the origin of the map makers
but it would become a map maker and it
would serve the will of the beyonders
and the whole purpose of the map makers
were to chart worlds where the molecule
man had been destroyed by the black
swans and then to chase them down so
literally what you had here is you had
doctor doom creating the black swans to
kill molecule men because those molecule
men were dying the beyonders ended up
creating the map makers to find the
black swans who were killing molecule
men so it was a cat and mouse game right
black swans did the killing the map
makers tried to find them and try to
stop them before they could kill any
more molecule men and so with that being
told
doctor strange now kind of asked the
question okay if that's the case
then why is it that black swan is
different the black swan that we met
never mentioned anything about a
molecule man she never mentioned
anything about wanting to destroy them
she was just annihilating worlds and the
response of dr doom is i relied on blind
faith
i told all the black swans that i had
here's what we're doing you have to
understand that what i'm doing is is
true right like you have to believe me
and where so many of them believed him
just through blind faith oh you had some
who didn't you had some who defected who
questioned his own his own methods right
who questioned what it was that he was
doing
those were the black swans that appeared
to the black swan that we saw
in the story that basically ended up
joining the cabal right the one that we
saw at the beginning of hickman's run
and so what they did is they became
disillusioned
that black swan ended up basically kind
of defecting and then trying to find a
way to basically destroy these various
worlds right but ultimately what she
wanted to do is she wanted to find a
world that she could inhabit she wanted
to stabilize the incursions right to
keep the
multiverse from dying and then once the
multiverse was was stabilized right and
she did that by virtue of just
destroying worlds hoping that like you
know that much like the black priest it
would all kind of stabilize and kind of
go back to normal and that the pendulum
would stop swinging from left to right
so to speak and basically find a resting
place
um she ended up doing that just so she
could basically find a world for her to
settle down in and then recreate her
family right that's her whole goal
that's why she's been doing what she's
been doing and so ultimately what
what dr strange ends up asking is if
they lost faith in you
then why what did they see that led them
to believe
that your your cause was not as
righteous as you made it out to be and
what dr doom ends up doing is opening
this kind of you know
kind of device or i guess it's kind of
holding self and he opens his holding
cell and he shows dr
doctor strange what's inside and doctor
strange is like my god like why
why would you do something like that
like what in the heck is going on
dr doom got this idea from from the the
council of reeds
what he ended up showing uh what he
ended up showing doctor doom or doctor
strange
was basically a containment device full
of molecule men
this thing is just full of them because
the response of doctor doom is as he
started to look around he asked the
question okay so if the beyonders are
all powerful
if the beyonders are these beings that
can do pretty much anything then the
question that has to be asked here is
what would happen if they discovered if
they captured a black swan and they
tortured her or they they read her mind
and the black swan told them everything
they wanted to know that i'm rebu malone
that i formed the black swans to destroy
molecule man across the multiverse what
stops them from going back in time and
like killing me when i'm a little kid or
stops me from going back in time and
killing me before i can start this
conquest and he says their powers are
what stop them that the the beyonders
despite all their abilities they're
restricted to their own timeline now
remember we covered that earlier that
the beyonders
are stuck in linear time they can't
travel back and forth
they can do anything they want to but
they can only go forward they can't go
into the past and so because of that his
idea is
as we destroy these molecule men that's
the reason why they didn't rewind time
and in in that universe and save those
molecule men they can't there's no way
for them to and so with me realizing
that i knew i found
i had a way to stop them right i knew i
had a way to do that that i could abduct
molecule men and if the molecule man
basically harnessed the power of a
beyonder and i wanted to destroy the
beyonders then instead of the these
various molecule men being detonated all
the same time to destroy the multiverse
why not detonate all of them in the face
of the beyonders and wipe out all the
beyonders
that way and that's exactly what he did
that doctor doom ended up basically
calling forth
challenging the beyonders and saying
like like come to me like it is i you
know that when he approaches this kind
of rift in space where the
honors were coming from the sort of
access portal to the beyond verse where
by the way
you do see the hammer of thor we'll
explain why it's there here in a little
bit because probably one of the greatest
moments in all of marvel's storytelling
he challenges and he calls forth to be
honors right where they basically say
like we are from beyond dreamers
destroyers all of reality our whim who
dares stand before us the response of
doctor doom is
i do and they say what is this doom
right some paltry man
playing something more than what he is
and he says fools i am the destroyer
i have broken worlds to taunt you i have
shattered universes to mock you i have
taken what is yours
and made it mine face me at your own
peril if you dare face me at all and so
in turn they realize
this is the guy that's been killing all
the molecule men right this is the guy
that got in the way of our plants and
they say for the short life left of
anything
men and women will weep at the stories
of what was done here
to you on this day and then in turn and
probably one of the greatest
and one of the greatest responses ever
right doom says i
say no one will ever hear the word
beyond her
again i will erase your name from
history itself and in their anger
the beyonders come come pouring out
towards doctor doom
and he starts to kind of open this
vessel right he starts to open this
device this this kind of containment
cell and he says
you dared to test us you dared to toy
with us i dare to throw back in your
face
damn your cause damn the cost you will
certainly
die and then suddenly doom starts to
realize this is not the way it was
supposed to go he sends
all these molecule men towards the
beyonders he does successfully manage to
wipe out
all the beyond right he does
successfully manage to kill them all but
inadvertently in the process
dr doom wiping out all the beyonders is
the reason why
we went from 100 000 from hundreds of
thousands of universes in the multiverse
down to less than two dozen he didn't
mean to do it but directly and
inadvertently dr doom is the reason why
the multiverse's destruction has been
sped up dr doom is the reason why
everything is going to die with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end uh in the next video we
will cover the
ending of it all as well as probably the
single greatest moment in the history of
thor
hyperion it is amazing but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
you